-Very exciting.
Season 47 of "SNL."
Three new cast members.
Ten new writers.
-A hundred.
-A hundred new writers?
-A hundred new writers.
I think it's part of
Biden's infrastructure plan?
-Oh, that's right. I saw that.
He's like, "We got to
get more writers in there."
-And the nice thing, I think,
is that luckily
we never win an Emmy
for writing --
because the statues
would bankrupt the Academy
if they ever had to give statues
to the whole...
-If they ever gave out a 100.
-It would end the Academy,
so that's nice.
-This is --
I was there when you started.
It's crazy to me now that --
I mean, I was only there
four years before you started,
but you were a kid
when you showed up.
And this is your I.D.
you still use.
-This is my current I.D., yeah,
that I have.
-Current I.D., and they --
Do they believe it's you?
-Yeah, 'cause it still scans.
Like, the security guards --
It scans,
and that's what comes up.
And they look at me,
and they're just like,
"Whatever. Just come in.
At this point, just come in."
It's truly like
if you had posted a photo
like you were kidnapped,
and there was a wanted photo out
there, and then they were like,
"Let's just use it for his I.D.
for his job for 20 years."
-"Hey, we found him. We rescued
him from the kidnappers.
Let's use it as his I.D."
-"Let's let him
never quite forget."
-People used to always
ask me this question.
Were there summer stories
you were bummed
not to be able to write sketches
about or tell jokes about?
-Yes, there were some.
There were stories.
There was the Cleveland Indians.
Did you see the --
They changed their name?
I don't know if you -- Do you --
Do you follow news stuff?
-Yeah, I do. [ Laughs ]
-The Cleveland Indians changed,
and there was a whole --
What I like is there was
a whole press conference
where the guy came out
and he was like,
you know, "We're not
the Cleveland Indians anymore.
We're gonna be the Cleveland
Guardians instead."
And I thought it would have been
really great if he'd come out
and been like,
"We're going with Redskins."
[ Laughter ]
"We did some research,
and we discovered
it actually recently
became available.
And we'd like --
We're gonna do Redskins."
And I also really liked --
there was a story about --
that they caught
a Catholic priest on Grindr.
Which I know you're like,
"And...?"
But there was a whole outrage
about this was happening,
and my thought was, "Isn't that
the best-case scenario?"
Like, truly, isn't that
what we've all kind of
wanted for years to happen?
For centuries.
There's then this issue
where repressed gay men
didn't know who
they could open up to,
and now there's an app
on their phone
that connects them to every
single gay man around them.
-Right.
-Like Professor X
putting on a helmet
and being able to see
all the mutants in the world.
-It's a Cerebro, right.
-I don't know that he was
having sex with all of them.
But, you know --
-He definitely wasn't.
-Could be why
he's in the wheelchair.
We don't know, but...
[ Laughter ]
I think that --
-He has Peyronie's?
[ Laughter ]
Professor X is for --
-He went...
Anyway, my point is,
I feel like kids out there
should probably be pooling
their lunch money together
to try to buy priests
premium access to Grindr.
-All right. That's really --
-And that's my other commercial
they're gonna...
-Hey, you were --
-You do edits and stuff, right?
-No, no.
Whenever we have people from
live TV shows, we do no edits.
-Oh, wow. That's great.
-You were on "Jeopardy!"
You weren't on "Jeopardy!"
-No, I was not.
-But your --
Let's just take a look.
-That would almost make
more sense, by the way,
if was the contestant,
than this.
-Let's take a look.
-Yeah.
-Recent Books for $800.
Kelly?
-Who's Conan O'Brien?
-That's incorrect.
-[ Beeping ]
-Looking for Colin Jost.
-All right. I think
that's a real burn on Conan.
'Cause someone was like,
"I want to punch him."
-He was locked and loaded
with it,
like, "Punchable face?
Conan. Go!"
-Now, is that something where
somebody tells you about it?
Like, how do you find out
it happened?
-Ye, I found out it happened
because my mom sent me the clip,
and she said,
"I would have gotten it."
[ Laughter ]
Thanks.
-She's like,
"I don't get Cosmo,
but I would have gotten that."
-And, yes, it's a very --
'Cause when you make -- when
you're a clue on "Jeopardy!",
you feel like you've made it.
-Yes.
-But then in that same moment,
you realize, "Oh, I have not."
-Well, I think it's interesting
to note how --
I mean, really what you want
is to be like
a $100 first-round...
You were $800.
You know what I mean?
There was some value
to getting that right.
-Yeah, I guess you do
have to work your way up --
-To the gimme.
You want to be in the Monday
"New York Times" crossword.
-Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
-Yeah, that's true.
I'm barely Saturday right now.
-But let's -- Thank God
it didn't happen again.
-Yeah. No. That would be --
-Let's try Harvard for $1,000.
-Alex?
-Writers and performers who have
gone from "The Lampoon"
to "Saturday Night Live"
include this young fellow,
who co-hosts "Weekend Update"
with Michael Che.
-[ Beeping ]
-And his name is Colin Jost.
[ Laughter ]
-First of all,
they somehow found a photo
worse than the one on my I.D.
-Yeah.
-Then, the other thing is,
Alex Trebeck went to Harvard
to a location,
filmed a clue, like,
"You're gonna like this one."
-Yeah.
-Dead silence.
-We're gonna use a picture.
We're gonna talk about
who he works with.
They really put that one on a...
-Every context that you
could possibly give me.
-Nothing.
-And then you could tell
when he had to reveal the name.
He just was like...
"Why did I do this?"
-That's really also
a double burn on Conan,
who also went to Harvard.
Nobody even guessed him
on that one.
They only guessed him
on the punchable face.
-We'd hit him, but I don't know
if he could go to Harvard.
Yeah, so that's cool.
-You won an award.
You won an Audie?
-Yeah.
Were you going to say "outtie"?
-I think maybe --
-Did I just win an Audi?
[ Laughter ]
-I won an Audie, yes,
which is very exciting.
I'm very conditioned
to not win any award ever,
so it was very --
I was very flattered
and very surprised.
For Best Audiobook,
for my book, which was cool.
-Which is
"Very Punchable Face."
And so you recorded
your own book.
-Yes.
-And you got an award.
That is a genuinely cool thing.
-It was so cool.
I didn't even know you could.
It was very cool.
David Sedaris announced it, who
was a hero of mine as a writer.
And -- When you go and you're
recording an audiobook,
the other part of it
is you're hearing --
You're reading out loud
what you already wrote
and is locked in.
And then as you're reading it
out loud, you're like,
"Oh, I would have
made some changes.
This whole paragraph
could have been a cut."
And I'll be like, "Can I, like,
punch this up a little bit?"
And the guy's like
"Sure. I don't care.
You can do
whatever you want here."
-"I thought you were just
reading it, man. Do whatever."
-"I'm not even checking
that it's the same book."
-Congrats on that.
-I could go on to Stephen
King's "It" for a while.
-Congrats on that. Congrats on
another season of "SNL."
How many is this for you?
I guess we could do the math.
16, 17?
-Oh, God, dude. I don't know.
-"SNL" returns for its
47th season this Saturday.
-Which sounds like a joke.
It really does. Season 47.
-47th season
with 47 new writers.
This Saturday at 11:30 p.m.
here on NBC with Owen Wilson
and musical guest
Kacey Musgraves.